les patrons d'orpea et korian deux des
plus grands groupe d'ehpad au monde se
défendre devant les sénateurs s'étaient
vraiment l'une c'est des séquences
fortes de l'actualité aujourd'hui au
rhdp a également visé par une plainte de
l'état et une enquête administrative
cécile à 6 ou
l'audition a commencé par une mise au
point les sénateurs ont cherché à savoir
si oui ou non orpea a voulu éviter la
publication de conclusions de deux
enquêtes sur la gestion de ces ehpad
auditionné hier la ministre déléguée
chargée de l'autonomie qui nous a
déclaré que le gouvernement souhaitait
rendre public le rapport igas igf mais
que cela n'était pas possible du fait de
l'opposition d'orpea nous n'avons jamais
sollicité la non publication de ce
rapport jamet les sénateurs ont ensuite
passé en revue toutes les critiques
dévoilé par le livre les fossoyeurs
notamment sur les recherches d'économies
à tout prix opérées par le groupe mais
surtout sur les mauvais traitements
infligés aux personnes âgées dans les
ehpad comme les escarres non soignée la
limitation des changes ou encore la
dénutrition ce qu'il y a vraiment cette
volonté de réduire au maximum le coût
journalier de la nourriture est
absolument pas aujourd'hui de la moitié
des résidants qui arrive en ehpad sont
dénutris la moitié d'entre eux la moitié
d'entre eux il faut le savoir et et un
an après les deux tiers d'entre eux on
retrouvait un profil bien meilleure il
n'y a pas de rationnement si le pdg du
groupe reconnaît des dysfonctionnements
il n'accepte pas pour autant
l'accusation d'un système organisé de
maltraitance devant les sénateurs
philippe charrier s'est engagé à trouver
des réponses il a notamment promis un
renforcement de l'autonomie des
établissements l'ouverture d'un dialogue
social avec les salariés mais aussi une
série de mesures pour redonner confiance
aux résidents et à leurs familles on va
mettre un numéro vert pour les résidents
patients les familles les proches on va
nommer des médiateurs on va créer des
comités d'éthique et des comités
d'éthique de proches des établissements
le directeur de rhdp à a aussi annoncé
le lancement d' états généraux du grand
âge dans tous ses établissements dès le
mois de mai et je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités dans ce débat et lise
richard bonsoir ça bienvenue vous êtes
journalistes auteurs de cette enquête
c'est son de maltraiter nos vieux publié
aux éditions du rocher pascal champvert
bonsoir poursuit le président de
l'association des directeurs au service
des personnes âgées j'accueille
également un serge guérin bonsoir
sociologue spécialiste des questions
liées au vieillissement matthieu
croissandeau et évidemment elle toujours
un mais à mes côtés peut-être une
question un peu général pour commencer
et lise richard qu'est ce que vous
retenez vous de ces auditions gisèle
c'était vraiment une
moment fort quand même c'est presque un
moment fort de du fonctionnement de
notre démocratie quand quand on voit ces
images comment vous avez vécu cette
journée c'est vrai que ce qui est
admirable c'est le fait que les
dirigeants d'orpea présente des excuses
donc face aux familles après il faut
voir si cette remise enfin
il y aura une réelle remise en cause des
dysfonctionnements graves qui ont été
dénoncées dans la quête de victoire
castanet et dans les dents les rapports
présentés et c'est là en fait on va voir
vraiment ces excuses sont sincères et
s'il ya une réelle volonté de changer
les choses pascal champvert ces
auditions mais aussi vous vous l'avez
évoqué les rapports des enquêtes
d'ailleurs administrative qui vont être
publié dans les prochains jours comment
c'est perçu par par les directeurs
d'établissement les directeurs au
service des personnes âgées que vous
représentez c'est un bienfait il fallait
le faire ou alors on est on est pris
finalement est amalgamé
à cette enquête comment vous commencez
vécu mais suite au livre de victor
castanet il fallait évidemment missionné
une enquête de l'igas de lits gf c'était
bien le moins c'était indispensable de
réagir compte tenu des accusations qu'il
porte à clé est ce que vous en surprises
ces accusations certaines m'ont
complètement surpris bien entendu on
pouvait pas imaginer un tel système
s'ils tentaient que l'igas et ligier fo
on le verra puisque le rapport on devait
l'avoir on ne fait pas la voir ont fait
leur la voir et on va l'avoir bon et on
verra ce que disent les inspecteurs
généraux bon donc bien entendu quand il
y à des dénonciations de ce genre il
faut qu'il y ait des contrôles c'est
clair et il faut qu'il continue à y
avoir des contrôles à chaque fois il ya
des dénonciations par contre nous ce que
nous disons clairement à l'ad-pa c'est
que ça des gardons c'est l'association
des directeurs lac au service des
personnes âgées qui regroupe les
directeurs d'établissements et de
services à domicile que je préside ce
que nous disons également les ehpad
année pour les établissements c'est
aussi les services à domicile mais aussi
les résidences autonomie les résidences
services seniors c'est ce qu' il faut
continuer à contrôler les établissements
les services à domicile sur lesquels on
a des soupçons de 3 4% de cupide stupide
mal organisé de je ne sais quoi mais
l'idée qu'il faudrait contrôler tous les
établissements est une absurdité totale
une absurdité totale parce que la
question orpea qui est une question qui
tient un groupe dont il faudra savoir si
et accessoirement leader mondial oui
quand il faudrait savoir accessoirement
cette entreprise soit non je ne dis pas
ça enfin aujourd'hui orpea accueille
environ 5% des personnes et j'ai aidé à
domicile ou en établissement
donc moi je veux qu'on fasse mieux pour
les personnes qui sont hébergés chez
orpea mais surtout je veux qu'on fasse
mieux pour les 100 % et de personnes
âgées qui sont aidées et donc peut faire
cela ça ne suffit pas de tirer à boulet
rouge sur orpea faut aussi s'occuper de
l'ensemble du secteur on y revient
évidemment sur l' on a le temps de
d'aborder cette question servira vous
êtes déjà venu à plusieurs reprise
débattre de la place des vieux dans
notre société je prononce depuis le
début de cette émission volontairement
le mot vieux parce qu'on a déjà on en a
déjà parlé ceni péjoratif il ya un lien
tabou qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de
ces auditions du fait que l'état
les parlementaires en l'occurrence là
les sénateurs s'empare de cette question
vous dites quoi vous dites enfin vous
dites ya une part d'hypocrisie quand
vous réagissez m la première chose et
vous l'avez dit un tout petit peu au
début une société ça marche avec un état
ça marche avec des élus mais ça marche
avec la société civile est là d'une
certaine manière et puis ça marche et
dans la société civile c'est évidemment
très diverses là on à la société civile
c'est un journaliste s'appelle un
contre-pouvoir à quatrième pouvoir c'est
quand même défini dans la démocratie
tocqueville 1 6 800 les grands auteurs
nous rappelle ça donc il fait son métier
et il sort quelque chose et du coup deux
autres acteurs majeurs les élus d'un
côté et l'état se disent peut-être qu'on
bouge mais c'est très bien de théâtre
d'une certaine manière c'est la société
dans son ensemble notre cas une grande
partie la société qu'ils aient bouge
futur un sujet qui ne concerne pas juste
les plus jeunes ah non c'est un truc de
vieux non c'est pas un truc de vieux
c'est un truc de tout le monde vous
pouvez avoir un grand parent une grande
berne un grand-père un iron eyes rohmer
qui est concerné et donc vous êtes
concerné qu'un jour ça sera peut-être
vous et puis entre temps peut-être vous
allez travailler dans le secteur du coup
vous y serez aussi concernés donc je
trouve de ce point de vue là très un
fantôme de charge symbolique menée de
réalité je trouve ainsi une démocratie à
qui marche mieux que ce qu'on dit
souvent puisque finalement les
l'ensemble des acteurs se mobilisent et
deuxième élément est bien sûr un secteur
mais toujours un petit peu de côté où
finalement tout le monde se dit faut
peut-être qu'on regarde et c'est aussi
la preuve que la société elle prend de
l'âge la société elle vit je rappelle
que notre futur à nous tous le futur
démographique du pays l'avenir des mois
le destin démographique du pays c'est le
vieillissement l'augmentation du nombre
de personnes dans le pays ça sera lié
uniquement au vieillissement donc c'est
important et c'est aussi pour ça on s'y
intéresse est ce que tous on se dit ça
pourrait être moi ouais et on peut
regretter qu'il faille un scandale comme
celui là pour que y ait un tel coup de
projecteur et un tel choc philippe au
crédit de la part des politiques ça fait
des années des décennies qu'on parle du
quatrième âge qu'on parle davantage
combat de la dépendance des décennies
que les candidats de droite de gauche
les présidents de droit de gauche disent
on va la faire ils ne font pas les
prémisses pareil il s'est quand même un
non-dit absolue dans la sphère politique
on est très content d'avoir les votes
des retraités mais pour s'attaquer au
sujet du grand âge on l'a jamais
vraiment vraiment fait alors il ya eu
des mesures y ait des plans jeu le pack
a rien eu mais il n'y a jamais eu cette
structuration d'un nouveau risque de la
sécurité sociale qui fait que
aujourd'hui la différence de 1945 on vit
beaucoup plus longtemps et puis il ya
aussi un malaise dans la part des
familles il faut le dire parce que c'est
aussi un non dit mais on se sent plus ou
moins parfois coupables de m
mamie maman dans un ehpad et on se sent
peut-être moins - d'aplomb pour
contester la gestion de l'ehpad où le la
façon dont est traitée
c'est son sang son parent ou sont en
parangon cocon qu'on a mis la même si ça
n'est pas une relégation mais voilà mais
ouais moi aussi quand on le vit grâce à
sa complexe aussi donc chacun je suis
d'accord avec vous tous les acteurs ont
joué leur jeu mais ça faisait longtemps
qu'on mettait la poussière sous le tapis
et vise richard c'est vous dénonciez à
peu près les mêmes choses que viktor
kassai dans votre livre cessons de
maltraiter nos yeux le titre et était
éloquent ça
chaque livre on pourrait provoquer un
scandale mais mais en fait l'état où les
différents pouvoirs bouge pas
suffisamment peut-être parce que la
société est face à ce tabou dans ton
dont on parlait mais c'est vrai que dans
le livre de victor castanet il ya des
faits qui était dénoncée depuis des
années et dans mon livre et dans
d'autres et dans d'autres documentaires
qui ont été diffusés ces dernières
années donc c'est des choses notamment
en ce qui concerne par exemple le
rationnement pour le coût des repas la
maltraitance institutionnelle liée au
manque de personnel etc tout ça c'est
des choses qui sont dénoncées depuis des
années et donc c'est vrai que les les
politiques ne peuvent pas feindre
aujourd'hui de découvrir
ces faits là et donc c'est vrai qu'on se
demande pourquoi et c'est malheureux il
a fallu attendre ce livre ce scandale
pour qu'enfin on s'empare de ce sujet
qui est un sujet ce gars lui disait qui
nous concerne tous et c'est vrai que ça
c'est regrettable en fait état il ya une
forme un peu en effectivement
d'hypocrisie là dedans est ce que c'est
vrai qu'on aurait pu s'en emparer bien
avant alors il ya l'hypocrisie de l'état
on est d'accord là dessus mais il ya
quand même la question de la
responsabilité des groupes qui sont
auditionnés qui était auditionné
aujourd'hui au sénat tient je vous
propose d'entendre un extrait l'audition
de philippe charrier c'est le patron le
pdg d'orpea il est devant la commission
denquête il dit que son groupe n'a pas
industrialisés l'accompagnement en fin
de vie écoutez c'est un métier l'humain
on industrialise pas l'accompagnement de
ponzi c'est impossible
sa patience tapas ans
l'accompagnement de fin de vie c'est un
métier extraordinairement difficile
humainement
on s'attache aux résidents on les voit
partir c'est un métier très dur donc en
aucun cas il s'agit d'industrialisation
trêpa d'industrialisation j'ai donné
quelques chiffres qui viennent de des
entreprises elles-mêmes le groupe orpea
ses trois cent soixante douze
établissements en france un chiffre
d'affaires 2021 de un peu plus de 4
milliards 4 milliard deux cents millions
d'euros en progression de 9 9% et une
marge de 24 9% si on regarde ensuite le
groupe korian on a 300 établissements
298 chiffre d'affaires similaires 4 3
milliards d'euros + 11 % et 20 % de
marge pascal champvert faire de la
marche c'est normal c'est même un signe
de de bonne santé on peut considérer que
c'est simple pour un groupe privé est-ce
que là cette marge elle ne se fait pas
quand même au détriment des clients on
se dit avec cette marge
orpea ou korian aurait pu embaucher plus
de personnel et donc se détacher de
cette maltraitance un peu
institutionnalisée dont on parlait à
l'instant
la maltraitance dont parlait lice
richard c'est une maltraitance dans tous
les établissements et tous les services
à domicile de france et je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec matthieu
croissandeau ça fait des années qu'on le
sait pourquoi parce que on ne passe pas
assez de temps auprès de nos aînés à
domicile et en établissement et ça ne
pas passer de temps auprès de gens qui
vont lentement qui ont besoin de temps
c'est en soi une maltraitance et
s'habiller et manque de personnalité un
allié vraiment le goût personnel comment
ça s'explique une part de l'état il ya
une part des groupes eux-mêmes expliquez
nous ce serait clairement nous ce que
nous préférons c'est qu'il y ait trois
cent mille chômeurs de moins et 300000
personnes qui viennent travailler auprès
des personnes âgées et vous verrez qu'on
réglera toutes les difficultés y compris
le manque d'attractivité de ses métiers
à domicile comme en établissement et ses
salles on l'a déjà expliqué ici mes
jours et que vous ne leur ai expliqué
pourquoi quelle est la part de l'état là
dedans dans la question de l' embauche
pourquoi l'état à une part de
responsabilité dans le fait qu'ils aient
pas suffisamment de personnel selon il
faut bien comprendre que orpea c'est 3 %
des personnes âgées qui vivent en
établissement les établissements
commerciaux comme orpéa ses 20% des
personnes âgées qui vivent en
établissement ces établissements là
c'est vrai fixe le prix payé par les
personnes âgées les familles pour le
dire rapidement de façon libre
80% du reste du secteur c'est-à-dire les
établissements publics ou associatifs
ils ne sont pas libres de leur budget
ils ont des budgets qui sont fixés par
les pouvoirs publics l'état et les
départements donc oui sans doute il faut
voir ce que font les établissements
commerciaux des moyens qu'ils ont et
incontestablement il faut voir ce
qu'orpea a fait des moyens qu'il a eu
c'est le rôle des deux inspections on
verra si les inspections confirme ou
infirme
manifestement elle confirme largement ce
qu'a dit ce qu'a écrit victor castanet
on le verra quand on aura en face au
rapport mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que pour 4 un bon sens
d'établissements publics ou associatifs
et donc 80% des personnes âgées qui
vivent en établissements et de la même
façon pour 80% des personnes âgées
accompagnées à domicile ce ne sont pas
les directeurs ou les établissements où
les services à domicile qui décide des
moyens ce sont les pouvoirs publics et
donc le manque de moyens dans 80 % de la
profession il est lié aux pouvoirs
publics j'irais même jusqu'à dire que
dans les établissements commerciaux le
manque de médecins d'infirmières de
psychologues d'aide-soignante il est
aussi lié aux pouvoirs publics parce que
pour cette partie là c'est l' agence
régionale de santé qui décide du nombre
de professionnels donc ayons en tête
qu'il ne faut pas voir la partie
immergée émerger parcours d'un iceberg
c'est à dire la ferrari perd ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que c'est l'ensemble du
système de l'aide aux personnes âgées
qui dysfonctionne comme vous l'avez dit
les uns et les autres et depuis très
longtemps mais quand même serge guérin
est ce que quand on fait 25% de dommage
on peut pas embaucher un peu plus de
monde dans l'embauché il ya plusieurs
éléments dont le premier s'est en effet
trouvé les trois cent mille c'est
l'attractivité existe à 300 il faut
l'écrire et tient donc c'est aussi
donner envie moi j'ai un master qui
forment plutôt les directeurs donc à bac
+5 donc l'élément il est un petit peu et
un petit peu différent oui aussi
d'ailleurs des progressions donc c'est
comment on
modernise on renouvelle toutes ces
filières là il ya vraiment des enjeux
importants c'est aussi la question du
management tient que est aussi une quête
d'autonomie qui est pas si simple que ça
à mettre en place mais il ya une demande
aussi forte des personnes d'être plus
autonome dans l'activité professionnelle
il ya les gens qui à domicile se sont
parfois plus seul c'est plus difficile
parfois de travailler à domicile prenez
votre voiture vous devez faire un nombre
de kilomètres incroyable pour aller voir
quelqu'un qui est fragile à 6,8 va donc
il ya tout ça aussi à accompagner très
très fortement donc c'est vraiment le
sien le le noeud gordien le coeur de la
guerre il est content il est quand même
là mais sur les personnels et comment on
favorise il ya une envie en plus et puis
c'est aussi des mythiques en dix ans or
ce qui est très intéressant c'est qu'on
voit qu'aujourd'hui la quête de sens
aller quand même absolument centrale
font les gens disent mais à quoi ça sert
à quoi ça sert et puis je ferai juste un
petit lien c'est on parle aussi de
passer la retraite plus tard et ainsi de
suite donc c'est aussi la question de
l'emploi y compris de gens plus âgés et
de comment on valorise l'emploi des gens
plus âgés et entre autres dans certains
cas des gens qui ont envie dans une
deuxième ou troisième partie carrière
d'aller travailler dans ces secteurs là
dans le monde des maisons de retraite
médicalisées ou du service à la personne
sait bien qu'il n'y ait pas partout vous
me direz mais là encore plus peut-être
sait bien qu'il n'y ait pas que des gens
de 20 ou 25 ans il ya besoin aussi de
gens plus âgés c'est aussi une dizaine
une des interrogations à porter je vous
donne la parole sur l'attractivité mais
j'aimerais vous entendre dans votre
enquête vous avez évidemment été en
contact avec énormément de deux salariés
de ces établissements
sur la perte de sens sur le conte appel
de turnover c'est à dire la difficulté
du métier qui fait qu' on abandonne au
bout de au bout de quelques temps
comment vous l'avez ressenti ça ce qui
est revenu très fréquemment en fait de
la part des professionnels du secteur
c'est le sentiment en fait de
frustration c'est à dire le sentiment de
ne pas pouvoir faire en fait son métier
correctement comment comme on l'a appris
et comme on devrait le faire et c'est à
dire que les soignants souffre en effet
de manque de temps de manque de pouvoir
accompagner les personnes âgées les
vieux comme il le faudrait donc pour des
toilettes qui sont faites en dix minutes
alors voilà qu'il faudrait au moins le
double des couches et pareil au lance
pierre et donc c'est ce manque de temps
principalement qui revient ce sentiment
de frustration oscillant dans les ehpad
mais aussi à domicile parce qu'à
domicile
les heures en fait le temps qui a
accordé par les départements par les
plans dead est très souvent insuffisants
et les aides à domicile les auxiliaires
de vie souffre aussi de manque de temps
pour accompagner les personnes chez
elles alors l'attractivité du métier
parce que vous dites il faudrait 300
mille personnes de plus mais
effectivement encore faut-il les
convaincre de venir travailler dans un
secteur et puis la séquence d'actualité
dont on parle n'êtes pas qu'il n'a pas
bonne image il faut commandes pour le
secteur d'un pas bonne image on est dans
une société hagist qui est une société
de discrimination qui discriminent les
gens en fonction de leur âge et qui
discrimine encore plus les personnes
très âgées 6 tient ici des propos
racistes homophobes et antisémites
je serai très vite condamné et
heureusement le problème c'est que
l'âgisme départ père est tellement la
société et hagist on dévalorise les très
vieux et on dévalorise le propre
vieillissement de chacun d'entre nous il
faut déjà expliqué ça bon premier
élément deuxième élément c'est métiers
sont des bons métiers ce sont des
métiers comme l'a dit serge guérin où on
accompagne des hommes et des femmes à
vivre mieux quand ils sont vieux et on
apprend beaucoup au contact des très
âgées ce sont de très beaux métiers mais
ces métiers ils ont été détruits ils ont
été malmenés par les pouvoirs publics
les pouvoirs publics qui n'ont pas voulu
faire suffisamment pour les très âgés et
qui ont fait économie / économie et ce
qui conduit à ce que dit lise richard
c'est à dire que les professionnels
n'ont pas le temps de s'occuper bien les
personnes âgées si demain on recrute 300
mille emplois trois cent mille salariés
supplémentaires dans le secteur de
l'aide à domicile et des établissements
eh bien ils passeront plus de temps et
ces situations invivables pour les
professionnels et pour les personnes
âgées cesseront alors vous allez me dire
on n'a pas formé suffisamment
d'infirmières ces dernières années et
l'état est d'ailleurs particulièrement
cynique lui qui n'a pas formé les
infirmières nous dit aujourd'hui c'est
pas la peine que je vous donne d'argent
puisque vous ne recruterait pas
d'infirmières que je n'ai pas fort mais
c'est quand même un cynisme absolument
terrifiant ça tombe bien on répond à
l'état on peut recruter d'autres
professionnels on peut recruter des
psychologues il y a un nombre
incalculable de psychologues aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont leur diplôme ou qui sont à un
an d'avoir le diplôme et qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi il y à des professionnels
de l'animation et de la vie sociale qui
pourrait avoir un emploi à domicile ou
en établissement il y a des
ergothérapeutes des psychomotriciens des
professionnels de l'aide à domicile que
l'on pourrait recruter et puis il y a
plein de professionnels que l'on
pourrait accueillir même sans diplôme et
que bien encadré bien l'accompagner à
partir du moment où on va on aura un
nombre de professionnels suffisant pour
accompagner sérieusement à prendre
des professionnels peu formés et donc là
on règle le problème après la question
c'est de savoir comment on va financer
tout ça j'ai quand même juste parce que
là vous parlez vous avez décrit
l'univers 20% privé 80% au public ou
associatif ou parapubliques et donc on
comprend qu'en fait tout le secteur
fonctionne à l'économie mais dans les 80
pensions publiques par manque de moyens
dans les 20 % privé par recherche du
profit quand même c'était la
démonstration du livre de victor
castanet avec le manque de moyens de
revendre dans le privé c'est quand même
pour la recherche du profit et de la
marge de bénéfice aux agissements
d'orpea probablement par la recherche
d'un profit excessif mais dans la
société française telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure thomas hugues on voit pas bien
pourquoi on reprochera une entreprise
privée de faire des profits ce qui est
scandaleux c'est les profits excessifs
au détriment de ceux pour les quarts
des personnes
on est parfaitement d'accord mais j'ai
dit à quel point l'aspect qui les
inspections générales étaient légitimes
alors il va falloir voir si
effectivement ce que dit victor castanet
est avérée si c'est avéré c'est
insoutenable mais une fois plus oui
concentrons nous sur cette question mais
n'oublions pas le reste de la question d
un peu envie d'oublier en ce moment et
ça a voulu intervenir oui c'était
simplement pour rebondir ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le fait que
orpea aurait les moyens on fait de
recruter davantage de personnel en effet
puisque c'est un groupe qui fait entre
100 et 200 millions de bénéfices par an
et donc très clairement il pourrait
recruter davantage de personnel le fait
est qu'ils en recrutent pas plus que les
dotations publiques voire même moins
justement et qui fait des économies donc
sur l'argent public et je pense que
en fait c'est lié aussi au fait
justement qui n'est pas assez de
dotation publique dans tous les
établissements c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas intérêt entre guillemets quand on
est un établissement privé lucratif a
embauché tellement plus que un
établissement public parce que il ya
forcément un effet de comparaison et à
partir du moment où il ya des dotations
qui sont faibles dans les établissements
publics ou les établissements
associatifs non lucratif ça ne pousse
pas le secteur privé si on voulait à
aller il se réalise mon public où il ya
je veux dire n'importe quoi x personnes
pas pour pour s'occuper 200
pensionnaires et binbin et bien j'ai pas
besoin d'en faire plus exactement fut
son col en fait il se contente du
minimum voire moins récents en masquant
les chiffres etc comme on l'a vu et donc
si on augmentait le ratio de personnel
et qu'on imposait un ratio minimum
décent ça obligerait nécessairement le
privé à saleh à sa lignée et peut-être à
faire mieux si après on instaurait aussi
peut-être des évaluations et c'est
intéressant vous avez évoqué plusieurs
fois ces rapports
denquête administratif cette fois ci je
pense que fanny conte qui doit être
juste cela derrière le rideau bonsoir
fanny vous nous rappeler le contexte de
cette double double enquête c'est ça
effectivement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure suite aux révélations du livre
de victor castanet qui met en cause donc
elle est pratique du groupe orpea le
gouvernement a lancé début février une
double enquête qui a été confiée donc à
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales l'igas et à l'inspection
générale des finances et le rapport a
donc été rendu il ya quelques jours hier
la ministre déléguée chargée de
l'autonomie brigitte bourguignon était
auditionné par la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur le contrôle des ehpad et au
cours de cette audition est bien la
ministre a donné les grandes lignes de
ce rapport et les faits qui sont donc
reproché au groupe orpea la ministre a
d'ailleurs rappelé que le gouvernement
avait saisi le procureur à ce sujet
écoute et ayant aucune intention de
laisser s'installer la moindre ambiguïté
qui viendrait alimenter les mauvais
procès politique que je vois fleurir
j'ai décidé avec olivier ferrand de
publi de publier le rapport d'ici
quelques jours en veillant bien sûr à
occulter les parties qui doivent l'être
si orpea confirme toujours ne pas
vouloir lever totalement le secret des
affaires bon il ya eu un souci au niveau
de l'extrême et c'est pas grave brigitte
bourguignon a rappelé aussi que l'état
demandera le remboursement des
financements publics qu'ils auraient été
irrégulièrement employés thomas la minus
qui est revenu également sur les mesures
qui ont déjà été plus effectivement un
concrètement en termes de contrôle la
ministre a demandé des enquêtes flash
par les ars notamment sur les ehpad
signalés entre février et mars vous
allez le voir un plus de 230
établissements ont été contrôlés de
manière inopinée plusieurs
dysfonctionnements majeurs ont été
identifiés conduisant pour 70 d'entre
eux à des injonctions des sanctions ça
représente quand même un tiers des
établissements contrôlés cela a été
jusqu'à la mise sous administration
provisoire d'établissement très
défaillant et même la fermeture de
certains établissements
par ailleurs la ministre a également
annoncé une cure de transparence en
actuellement il faut savoir qu environ
10% des 7400 ehpad de france sont
contrôlés dans les deux prochaines
années eh bien tous les ehpad seront 6
matic mans contrôler l'objectif est de
poursuivre ce rythme c'est ce qu'a
annoncé la ministre hier et puis il y
aura aussi 150 embauches supplémentaires
pour les ars pour effectuer ces
contrôles par ailleurs le gouvernement
prévoit la mise en place de 10
indicateurs qui permettront d'évaluer
les établissements et ainsi éclairer le
choix des familles ces indicateurs
concerneront notamment les taux
d'encadrement de rotation des personnels
d'absentéisme le profil des chambres le
plateau technique des établissements ou
encore le budget quotidien pour les
repas enfin sachez que les comptes des
ehpad devront être plus clair et plus
détaillés et puis en termes de
calendrier la ministre a annoncé que
toutes les modifications réglementaires
seront prises rapidement par décret
avant la fin du quart et donc en ce qui
concerne le rapport on l'a déjà un peu
évoquée mais finalement est-ce qu'il
sera diffusée très basse et l'extrait
que vous avez entendu dans un objectif
de transparence la ministre a annoncé
que ce rapport de l'igas et 10 gev sera
donc bien publier dans les jours qui
viennent en supprimant les passages
soumis au secret des affaires la
ministre a en effet assuré que le
gouvernement ne s'était jamais opposé à
la publication de ce rapport pour
brigitte bourguignon c'est orpea qui
s'opposaient à ces diffusions au nom du
secret des affaires on l'a entendu merci
fanny et de patrons leur pays a
d'ailleurs qui a été interrogé là-dessus
aujourd'hui
dit que non pas du tout et il était
d'accord pour que ce rapport soit soit
publié dans le respect du secret des
d'aider à faire sur ces contrôles serge
guérin le
moment je suis un béotien je connais je
connais évidemment beaucoup moins le
secteur que vous jeu j'avais le
sentiment est aussi en lisant le livre
de victor casas n'est que bon on soit
les établissements étaient prévenus du
contrôle soit y en avait pas
suffisamment est ce que vous vous diriez
qu'il ya eu des lacunes en la matière
depuis des années et que enfin on prend
ça à voir le corps qu'à une logique mais
un état qui est là entre autres pour
contrôler partie son job encore plus
s'il ya des moyens publics qui sont mis
à disposition il le fait on le fait par
mois pour les collèges pour les lycées
pour les écoles on va pas remettre en
cause tous les collèges il peut y avoir
aussi des problèmes dans les collèges
ainsi tué mais c'est normal qu'il y ait
des contrôles si on prend le cas
allemand par exemple il ya des contrôles
très réguliers une fois par an il ya
même de contrôler un hacker uniquement
centré sur le résident et un autre qui
est plutôt centré sur l'organisation il
suffit donc on peut alors après faut pas
rentrer dans une société de contrôle
mais bref se dire qu'il peut y avoir des
contrôles ne me semble pas me semble pas
dire je sais pas si on peut en faire
7500 et tous à kanfen l'autre élément en
effet c'est de se dire si un contrôle et
si on prévient tout le monde avant on
est tous pareils si les ide inspection
ben voilà où vous allez vous préparer
bon ainsi suite ça ça fait partie du jeu
donc là l'idée en effet c'est qu'il
puisse y avoir des contrôles qui
d'ailleurs je pouvait se faire aussi
aujourd'hui après c'est décidé de le
faire avec des gens
compétents informé pour le faire capable
aussi d'aller voir capable aussi de
comprendre les conditions de travail des
personnes les situations la cifit donc
il ya un travail de réflexion et encore
une fois que ce soit un contrôle aussi
qu'ils soient qualitatif c'est pas juste
vérifier les chiffres étaient deux
chiffres de nos invités quand même
délieront qu'ils soient prévues avant
c'est même choquant vous avez des
services vétérinaires vous avez l'urssaf
ils font du contrôle sur pied ce sans
prévenir personne je n'ai pas dit que
c'était bien olic en effet
les éléments s'étaient qu' on peut
considérer normal encore une fois quand
on vient de faire un contrôle dans un
collège andré luiz est situé c'est
normal de le faire et l'état décide de
le faire ou leur l'ordination qu'il
représente le fait sans nécessairement
revenir et c'est dans la logique des
choses sinon en effet ça on sait bien
qu'on s'y prépare
je voudrais entendre un extrait d'une
autre audition c'était celle du
directeur général du groupe korian a
quitté lui aussi entendu auditionné au
sénat aujourd'hui alors justement sur
cette question des contrôles il faisait
une sorte de bilan après année après
année au regard des
2018 on a eu 13 contrôles pour toute la
france en 2019 on a eu 10
en 2020 on en a eu 7
21 on en a eu sept également c'est
important de se dire que ces contrôles
sont qualité quand ils sont faits ils
sont de 2,2 de qualité et donc on peut
avoir des injonctions des
recommandations des observations ou des
contrôles qui sont totalement contact
totalement vierge en général inopinée ou
pas il est extrêmement rare d'avoir des
inspecteurs qui arrivent le matin et qui
sortent leur lettre de mission et qui
viennent contrôler de vraiment le
contrôle inopiné en revanche le contrôle
très très très rapide oui ça c'est
embêtant c'est comme ça que ça se passe
pascale sanvert sur sur les conditions
de ces contrôles le fait que
l'établissement finalement soient
prévenus c'est ce qu'on entend aussi la
de du témoignage du directeur général du
groupe korian
mais que je ne sais pas si l'état est
naïf ou cynique avec cette affaire des
contrôles oui je le redis quand il y a
des doutes sur un établissement ou un
service à domicile suite par exemple au
livre de victor castanet bien sûr il
faut faire des contrôles pour le reste
l'idée même de contrôle est un pur
scandale dans le secteur de l'aide aux
personnes âgées pourquoi parce que ça
n'est pas la peine d'aller vérifier les
établissements y les services à domicile
pour voir si ça fonctionne mal moi je
vous le dis ici publiquement ça
fonctionne mal dans les établissements
et dans les services à domicile nous ne
faisons pas ce que nous devrions faire
pourquoi parce que depuis vingt ans
l'état qui n'a pas donné suffisamment de
moyens n'a cessé de donner des ordres
supplémentaires et donc demain on fait
un contrôle dans tous les établissements
dans tous les services à domicile on
trouve partout qu'on ne fait pas
suffisamment bien pour les personnes
âgées qu'on prévienne compris viennent
pas donc nous disons servirait évoqué
tout à l'heure le cas de l'allemagne oui
mais en allemagne ils ont le minimum
décent il ya huit professionnels pour 10
personnes âgées en établissement
c'est ce que l'état a promis en 2006
pour 2012 pas n'importe qui le premier
ministre de l'époque dominique de
villepin a lancé un plan 2006 en dix ans
en 2012 il faudra qu'il y ait huit
professionnels pour 10 personnes âgées
dans les établissements est l'équivalent
à domicile dix ans après on est à peine
assise pour 10 alors ce que nous disons
nous c'est que le jour où il ya huit
professionnels pour 10 dans l'établé des
établissements c'est à dire le jour où
l'état aura fait son métier le jour où
l'heure
missile sera à 30 euros ce que toutes
les études montrent comme étant
nécessaire à ce moment là oui on pourra
venir demander aux directeurs aux
professionnels ce qu'ils auront fait des
moyens qu'ils auront été accordé mais
tant que ça n'est pas le cas l'idée même
de contrôler et surtout un contrôle par
ceux-là même état et départements qui ne
donne pas les moyens à 80%
d'établissements et de services à
domicile un contrôle n'a strictement
aucun sens et donc si je vous pose la
question si nice ou naïveté est ce que
l'état croit qu'il va vraiment faire des
contrôles ou est ce que l'état c'est
très bien qu'ils ne les fera pas en tout
état de cause cette annonce est
totalement stupide oui mais alors
j'entends totalement vos arguments mais
dans la gamme de la maltraitance
voilà il ya un certain nombre de yadana
ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire qu'il faut arrêter tous les
contres à limoges à la marge et les
établissements dans lequel il ya des
signalements il ya où les familles qui
se plaît mais je les dis quand il y à un
signalement à domicile ou en
établissement contrôle aucun problème
mais quand on nous dit faut contrôler
100% des établissements est d'ailleurs
que ce soit mon oubli les services à
domicile là je dis naïveté ou cynisme
non il faut d'abord que l'état cesse de
détourner l'attention du grand public en
nous faisant nous focaliser sur la
question d'orpea qu'il faut bien entendu
traiter je ne dis pas le contraire mais
il faut cesser de faire croire qu'il n'y
aurait qu'un problème orpea alors qu'il
ya un problème dans l'ensemble des
établissements et services et plus
généralement comme l'a dit serge guérin
dans l'ensemble de la société sur le
regard que nous portons sur les plus
vieux et lise richard vous qui avez
enquêté sur sur ce sujet ce que vous
êtes d'accord si vous parlez aussi
d'hypocrisie c'est à dire que je pense
que avant de faire des contrôles il faut
en effet augmenté le ratio de personnel
pour les résidents c'est à dire que
comme disait monsieur champvert c'est
évident que tous les établissements
quelles que soient leurs statuts
n'ont pas assez de personnel et donc il
ya de la maltraitance institutionnelle
et de la maltraitance parfois autres à
différents niveaux comme vous le disais
mais les contrôles ne peut ne peuvent
pas fonctionner si on n'augmente pas le
personnel donc la priorité c'est
évidemment à mon sens d'augmenter lé
ratio de personnel et aussi vous l'avez
souligné de pouvoir mieux former les
personnels parce que le problème aussi
c'est la formation notamment du
personnel soignant et l'emploi trop
récurrentes de faisant fonction qui
n'ont pas d'expérience parfois ni
diplôme et c'est là aussi un une des
grandes
un des grands dysfonctionnements dans le
secteur si on essaye d'esquisser des
solutions pour terminer ce débat serge
guérin pour voir notre vieillissement
plus comme une chance parce qu'on peut
aussi considérer que c'est une chance
que nos générations ont de pouvoir
vieillir en essayant de bien vieillir
c'est quelle solution vous vous imaginez
pour le futur ou la futur locataire de
l'elysée alors d'abord vous avez raison
on a une chance extraordinaire de
vieillir plus longtemps voilà on vit
quasiment le double de nous aérer ans
part en 1903 c'est quand même faut se
rappeler de ça mais pour que ce soit une
bonne chance d'une certaine manière il
faut être évidemment le mieux
accompagner possible premier enjeu
majeur s'appelle la prévention la
meilleure solution pour c'est quand même
d'agir le plus tôt possible en termes de
prévention qui nous donne plus de chance
c'est pas gagner à tous les coups mais
qui vous donne plus de chances de bien
vieillir et d'avoir moins de perte
d'autonomie ainsi de suite ça c'est
quand même un élément majeur ça veut
dire aussi des moyens et ça veut dire
aussi une ambition politique ça veut
dire eu une envie un désir un désir de
prévention veut dire on décide de
travailler sur ces sujets là ou plutôt
possible y compris d'ailleurs dans
l'accompagnement des salariés parce que
parfois les gens qui aident les fragiles
sont eux-mêmes fragilisé camp d'essai
est compliquée des délais fragile quand
même vous est fragilisée donc cette
prévention c'est aussi peau y compris
parfois une fragilité sociale économique
de transport bon voilà bien tout ça
ensuite deuxième élément en effet c'est
quand même à me donner c'est la question
de l'argent c'est aussi un choix
politique est ce qu'on met de l'argent
là où pas saisir c'est un choix
politique qui nous concerne tous il ya
eu combien de manifestation pour dire on
met plus d'argent sur les vieux cons
bien eu dans la rue combien de gens qui
la disent voilà je découvre ce n'est pas
bien ce qui se passe mais combien de
personnes sont allées dans la rue pour
dire il faut mettre plus d'argent sur
les lieux combien c'est aussi donc c'est
un peu facile à prédire ils sont pas
bien mais qui a poussé les politiques
pour en faire plus c'est pas si simple
que ça donc là aussi ça et je dirai
simplement dans est-ce qu'on peut pas
être non plus totalement négatif et
autres il ya eu quelque chose après
faudra voir ce qu'on en fait mais dans
le premier rapport ce l'élément majeur
structure ans et pierre laroque
l'inventeur de la sécurité sociale qui
en 1962 publie premier rapport il aurait
sur la sécu et éducatrices qui on en a
oublié un
vieillissement
1962 et donc il faut monter d'une
manière ou d'une autre le cinquième
risque de sécurité sociale c'est après
six décennies c'est ça pris six
décennies en 2020 patatras l'assemblée
nationale vote le principe l'assemblée
j'ai bien compris n'a pas le droit de
dire la dépense beau dire juste principe
est ainsi vite mais n'empêche que après
une fois quel principe donc la poterie
existe mais là qui existait un véhicule
comme on dit qu'on va faire sérieux
agents revoilà et ensuite c'est à la
scène et sa 2ème et sa caisse nationale
de solidarité pour l'autonomie merci
pascal il y siège mais ça va céder sa
ensuite de définir les moyens donc là il
ya un autre sujet encore faut-il que les
succès de moyens ça veut dire que depuis
deux ans ça n'a pas été définie ça non
hors ca 2007 fin 2020 le vote mais voilà
bon le temps mais ok mais en tout cas et
c'est sans doute pas alors après il faut
qu'une pression politique et une
pression de tous pour que l'on mette de
l'argent sur cet élément là et je
rappelle dernière chose quand on met de
l'argent sur le sujet du vieillissement
ce soit en prévention ou ce soit sur
l'accompagnement des gens fragiles on
n'est pas en jette pas l'argent par et
fritz et des emplois derrière c'est une
qualité de vie derrière c'est même une
capacité pour la france d'être meilleure
figure est donc on est tous
collectivement gagnant sur les capable
de mettre plus de moyens sur ce sujet
allez une bonne idée je donne la parole
pour pour conclure une bonne idée pour
nous aider à rester chez soi dans de
bonnes conditions le plus longtemps
possible parce que ça c'est le
souhaitent
immense majorité alors si on veut rester
chez soi le plus longtemps possible on
est absolument certain qu'à un moment ou
un autre la personne ayant par exemple
des troubles cognitifs la famille ne
saura pas quoi faire il se passera ce
qu'a dit matthieu croissandeau dès le
début qui est très important on va
obliger la personne âgée à rentrer dans
un établissement et du coup là se
développent de la culpabilité donc non
il faut jamais rester chez soi le plus
longtemps possible il faut d'entendre
aujourd'hui sur angers non non c'est pas
ça le truc il faut avoir le choix quand
on a dans son entourage quelqu'un qui à
80 ans il faut lui dire si un jour tu as
des difficultés physiques ou psychiques
est ce que tu voudrais rentrer dans un
établissement et autour de toi ou autour
de chez nous nous les enfants qu'elle
serait l'établissement et quel serait le
type d'établissement dans lequel tu
aurais envie de venir vivre ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose très me
transformer tous les établissements
domicile regrouper faire que les
établissements deviennent des domiciles
est ce qu'on fait les danois c'est un
match extrêmement bien c'est inverser la
logique merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat lise
richard cessons de maltraiter nos yeux
c'est le titre de votre livre enquête
publiée aux éditions du rocher maire